المغرب والجزائر إلى أين؟
الإخوة الذين سيتحولون لأعداء بمجرد أن تدق طبول الحرب بينهما،
ورائحة البارود تفوح في الأفق،
والتشديدات العسكرية على أشدها،
هل ستهدر الدماء العربية بأيد عربية؟
ما هذا الجنون؟
هل يسمح المغاربة وأهل الجزائر للأدوات الإعلامية بإشعال الفتن بينهما؟
هل ستكون الشقيقتان
العربيتان المسلمتان ساحة لتجريب أسلحة الدول الغربية؟
فالغرب لم يجد مكانا ليجرب هذه الأسلحة،
ويبدو أنه وجد حقل تجارب أسلحته   في هاتين الدولتين الشقيقتين.
ولماذا لا يتدخل العرب لتهدئة النفوس بين
الجارتين،
أوليس هدم الكعبة حجرا حجرا أهون عند الله من إراقة دم مسلم؟
وهل الوعود الغربية
بدعم هذا الطرف أو ذاك في صالح الشقيقتين؟
أم أن الفائدة كلها ستعود عليهم؟
فهم سيبيعون أسلحتهم للأشقاء وسيجنون أموالهم.
لكن الأشقاء لن يجنوا غير الدماء والدمار والخراب.
وماذا لو استعمل المغاربة والجزائريين أموالهم
لبناهم التحتية ولتطوير بلدانهم
ألن تنتفع بها شعوبهم وتذهب عنهم أفكار الدمار والخراب؟
فالحرب ليست مغامرة شيقة تنتهي بنهاية سعيدة
كما يستمتع بها المشاهدون في نهاية الأفلام السينمائية،
بل إنها كارثة تحرق نارها الأخضر واليابس،
وتأكل المال العام، وتعقد الأحوال الاقتصادية للمواطنين
الأزمة المغربية الجزائرية
تواصل الأزمة بين الجزائر والمغرب اشتدادها،
كما أنها تستحوذ على المشهد في وسائل الإعلام الدولية والرأي العام،
وهناك تستمر المقارنة العسكرية وإحتمال اندلاع الحرب بين الطرفين.
ويرى الغرب هذه الأزمة من منظار آخر هو بيع
وتجريب أسلحتهم المتطورة،
كل ذلك لأن ما يجري في الضفة الجنوبية الغربية للبحر الأبيض
المتوسط
بدأ ولأول مرة منذ قرون يهدد التوازن العسكري في المنطقة.
وبينما تمر العلاقات المغربية الجزائرية بأزمة
لم يسبق لها مثيل خلال الفترة الماضية،
ما دفع الجزائر لإغلاق مجالها الجوي في وجه الطيران
المغربي وقطع العلاقات الديبلوماسية بينهما.
وتتهم الجزائر جارتها المغرب بالتورط في
مخططات غربية إسرائيلية لتفكيك الجزائر،
ما يهدد باحتمال وقوع حرب بين الطرفين، بعدما
بدأت مؤشرات مقلقة في ظل حشد عسكري على الحدود بين البلدين.
ويظهر أهم ملف للتوتر من جديد
بين الجارتين وهو النزاع حول الصحراء،
فمنذ عام 1975، وفي السياق الأوسع للصراع على الصحراء،
سمحت الجزائر لجبهة البوليساريو بإدارة مخيمات اللاجئين
الصحراويين
في الصحراء الجزائرية جنوب غربي البلاد
فلطالما أظهرت الجزائر دعمها "الثابت وغير القابل للتفاوض" لجبهة البوليساريو.
وظلت البوليساريو تجد تزويدها بالأسلحة
والمعدات العسكرية من الجزائر وليبيا
وكوريا الشمالية وتستعملها في حربها ضد المغرب.
ويعتبر المغرب منطقة الصحراء جزءا لا يتجزأ من
وحدته.
ومع انضمام المملكة إلى منظمة الاتحاد الإفريقي
وسحب الاعتراف بالجمهورية العربية الصحراوية الديمقراطية
من قبل العديد من الدول الإفريقية،
فقد أسهم ذلك في إضعاف الموقف الجزائري داخل المنظمة.
تسليح المغرب والجزائر.
وتجري عملية التسلح للطرفين بشكل جنوني حيث
أنهما يتصدران قائمة مبيعات الأسلحة في القارة الإفريقية.
ولا تشهد جارتان تنافسا في التسليح
بهذا المستوى في العالم بقدرهما
إلا كوريا الشمالية وجارتها الجنوبية
وربما السعودية وإيران أيضا.
وبحسب بيانات وكالة التجارة الأمريكية فقد
تضاعفت المبيعات العسكرية من واشنطن إلى الرباط
وارتفعت من أربعة مليارات دولار في عام 2020
إلى 8 مليارات ونصف المليار دولار هذا العام،
بينما يوضح التقرير أن الجزائر بدورها رفعت ميزانيتها العسكرية
بقيمة 700 مليون دولار لعام 2022 بزيادة تقارب 7.8 % مقارنة بعام 2021
لتصل إلى تسعة مليارات وسبعمائة مليون دولار.
ومنذ 2015 بدأ المغرب والجزائر
بامتلاك أسلحة متطورة ونوعية،
حيث تراهن الجزائر على الصناعة العسكرية الروسية والصينية
ونسبيا الألمانية،
بينما لم يعد المغرب يراهن فقط على الصناعة العسكرية الأمريكية والفرنسية.
بل الصينية والتركية أيضا
الجزائر أول دولة تحصل على أسلحة نوعية للغاية
مثل منظومة الدفاع إس أربعمئة قبل الصين،
بل وحصلت على نظام الضرب بالغواصات من قاع البحر ضد أهداف برية منذ عام 2019،
وهي تقنية تمتلكها دول قليلة في العالم آخرها فرنسا منذ السنة الماضية،
بينما الدولة الثالثة التي لديها هذه
القدرة هي إسرائيل
ولا تمتلكها لا تركيا ولا إسبانيا ولا حتى إيطاليا.
ويبقى هدف روسيا الأول من تسليح الجزائر
بأسلحة نوعية وتحويلها إلى حليف استراتيجي
يكون شوكة عند الحدود الجنوبية للحلف الأطلسي،
أي غرب البحر الأبيض المتوسط
من إيطاليا إلى البرتغال.
وعمليا. لقد نجحت موسكو في الرهان،
ويرى الغرب في الجزائر مصدر خطر لدول جنوب أوروبا.
في الجانب المقابل، يعمل المغرب على تنويع
مصادر شراء الأسلحة، ويركز كثيرا على الصين،
ومؤخرا على تركيا.
ويكفي أن نظام مضاد للطيران المتطور الذي يحمي
بشكل كبير وقوي المجال الجوي المغربي،
هو من صنع صيني، ويسمى الدرع الدفاعي ألفين.
كما أن سلاح الدرع الذي يمتلكه المغرب ورادعة
صينية من نوع بي إتش إل سي ثري،
وبدأ يراهن كثيرا على الصناعة العسكرية التركية، وكانت
البداية
مع الطائرات المسيرة المتطورة بيرقدار تي بي 2.
لماذا كل هذا الجنون بين البلدين الشقيقين
بينما يمكنهم حل خلافاتهم على طاولة الحوار إن أرادوا ذلك؟
وعليهم عدم الذهاب وراء آراء الغرب، فكل همهم هو بيع أسلحتهم وتجربتها في أرض الجارتين المتنازعتين،
وفي النهاية هم أيضا من سيستفيدون من الموارد الطبيعية لـ الجارتين
وهنا نوضح لكم مفهوم التوازن النسبي
في المجال العسكري،
وهو أن خسائر المنتصر ستكون مثلها مثل خسائر المنهزم في الحرب،
وهو الوضع الحالي لدى ضفتي غرب البحر المتوسط.
هذا التطور الذي جعل الغرب لا يقلق كثيرا من
اندلاع حرب بين المغرب والجزائر،
بل يستبشر بها لأن الحرب تعني استهلاك أسلحة متنوعة ضد
بعضهما البعض وليس ضد دولة غربية.
ويجدر القول أن الجارتين الشقيقتين قد انفقتا
على التسليح أكثر من 140 مليار دولار،
منها 100 مليار دولار للجزائر،
أي ما يعادل أكثر من ضعف ما أنفقته المغرب.
أرقام مهولة تعادل ميزانيات ضخمة للعديد من
الدول،
أولم يكن يجدر بي الشقيقتين أن تنفقا هذه المبالغ الطائلة للتطوير في البلدين،
فقرار الحرب بسيط جدا وما اسهله،
ولكن لا يعلم إلا الله متى ستنتهي هذه الحرب إن قامت،
والمتضرر الأول والأخير هما الشعبان الشقيقان
فويلات ولعنات الحرب ستظل جاثمة عليهم لقرون من الزمن؟
فهل من متعظ؟